notre seat du vendredi avec Béatrice
Alain directrice générale du Chantier de
l'économie sociale bonsoir et Jacinthe
Eve Harel spécialiste en développement
des affaires qui a été candidate du
Parti conservateur du Québec à la
dernière élection bonsoir madame arelle
merci d'être avec nous on va parler des
VUS et de la taxation possible des
véhicules utilitaires sport
Pierre-Olivier Pineau de la chair du
secteur de l'énergie de HSC Montréal a
publié son rapport sur l'état de
l'énergie comme à chaque année il a fait
cette semaine et avec la popularité qui
est quand même toujours grandissante des
VUS il disait l'émission lundi qu'il
faut taxer les viv pour décourager leur
utilisation et le et l'achat des vies US
voici tout de suite ce qu'il disait
si comme société on voulait avoir un
comportement globalement responsable on
mettrait des freins à cette
prolifération de gros véhicules pour des
raisons économiques avant tout parce que
ça coûte cher ça crée de la congestion
ça ralentit la productivité sur les
routes et les freins on les connaît ils
sont pas populaires mais c'est des taxes
à l'achat pour les gros véhicules des
taxes supplémentaires pour l'essence des
taxes sur le stationnement
alors est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
Béatrice année d'abord mais je pense que
l'enjeu pour moi c'est la croissance
constante de notre parc automobile
l'état de nos routes puis l'état de
notre transport en commun ça ça a des
impacts clairement sur l'environnement
mais aussi économique et sociaux quand
on est poignée des heures dans les
bouchons de circulation donc il faut
réfléchir à comment on donne des choix
pour faire mieux oui sur le type de
véhicule qu'on achète mais aussi sur
l'usage du véhicule est-ce qu'on peut
l'utiliser moins parce qu'on a d'autres
options et donc pour répondre et moi
clairement est-ce que est-ce que faut
taxer les vues Béatrice Alain je pense
que ça fait partie du panier de solution
mais en décourager une option faut aussi
avoir des alternatives ok je comprends
bien votre réponse à vous madame Harel
je crois pas que la proche punitive et
coercitive soit la solution alors il
faut regarder la problématique de
décarbonate des carbonation avec un
ensemble de solutions et je pense pas
que de prendre les familles qui ont
besoin par exemple exemple d'une
camionnette ou des gens qui habitent en
région et qui ont besoin à cause du
climat à cause des régions à cause de
leur situation de vie les pénaliser ou à
adopter une approche coercitive taxée
n'est pas le problème par contre le
rapport de Monsieur Pinault et est un
outil fort intéressant et faire
pertinent dans l'analyse des solutions
qu'on peut mettre en place en termes de
politique publique pour des carboniser
et le rapport de Monsieur Pinot dit
aussi que la popularité des vies et des
gros camions même électrique nous
éloignent de nos objectifs de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
madame Arel je reste avec vous est-ce
que justement sur le plan écologique
compte tenu qui a des objectifs à
atteindre est-ce qu'il faut pas poser
une action punitive également
il faut poser des actions effectivement
mais dans ce rapport-là ce qu'on
mentionne c'est que depuis 2002 depuis
l'an 2000 la croissance de la population
c'est effectuée à hauteur de 17% au
Québec et les GES nos émissions de GES
n'ont pas bougé ils ont resté stable
malgré une croissance de la population
de 17%. donc en ce sens-là il y a
plusieurs éléments dans ce rapport-là
qui démontent qu'on fait bonne figure
faut pas oublier non plus que le Québec
produit 11% des GES du Canada et le
Canada produit un point 5% des GES dans
le monde donc en ce sens là en matière
de décarbonate de bicarbonation oui il
faut prendre faut mettre en place des
politiques publiques mais il faut
regarder la situation dans son ensemble
pour être en mesure d'avoir des
politiques publiques à fort impact puis
qui sont pertinentes je pense pas que de
taxer les vies soit une action à faire
impact et qui soit pertinent contenu des
chiffres que je viens de donner il y a
beaucoup de nos téléspectateurs qui nous
ont dit que les routes sont en Piat que
les véhicules util m'intéresse pas donne
quand même un sentiment de sécurité
et qu'il faut traîner des lourdes de
charge puis bon il y a les enfants
également est-ce que c'est valable
Béatrice Alain pour vous pour justifier
l'acquisition d'un véhicule utilitaire
sport mais je pense qu'il faut regarder
que les gens les je pense qu'il faut
prendre en considération que les gens
font des choix en fonction des options
qui s'offrent à eux quand les routes
sont en mauvaise conditions puis que les
distances sont grandes puis qu'on a pas
d'option de covoiturage quand on n'a pas
transport en commun quand il y a pas de
service de proximité qui nous permettent
de faire nos achats à pied ben oui ça
prend un gros véhicule mais c'est sur
l'ensemble de ces facteurs qu'il faut
agir et pas juste permettre l'achat de
vos véhicules et quand madame Harel dit
par exemple et souligne ce que dans le
rapport comme quoi nous sommes en
croissance démographique mais on est
quand même stable au niveau de nos
émissions est-ce que est-ce qu'on doit
se dire ben voilà on fait quand même
bien on n'a pas ajouté une taxe Béatrice
Alain mais pour moi c'est clair que on
peut faire faire mieux que l'enjeu de
toute façon l'enjeu environnemental est
un enjeu global puis le Québec peut
faire sa part je veux dire on consomme
une majorité des ressources et on a une
majorité de ressources et on sait qu'on
peut faire mieux le nombre de voitures
est en croissance au Québec par individu
il y a des solutions à ça mais il faut
donner des choix aux gens pour qu'ils
puissent faire un choix est-ce qu'on
doit
travailler auprès des concessionnaires
des constructeurs parce que c'est les
constructeurs qui les fabriquent quand
même ces véhicules là en fonction de la
demande mais ce qui est-ce qu'on doit
s'attaquer davantage à ces constructeurs
puis éventuellement au concessionnaire
madame Arel
la décarbonation c'est un peu comme un
jeu d'échec et quand on pense à taxer
par exemple les vies ou quand on pense à
blâmer les constructeurs automobiles
c'est comme si on regarde notre jeu
d'échec en regardant seulement quelques
cases et seulement deux ou trois pièces
de notre jeu d'échec il faut regarder
l'ensemble des 64 cases et l'ensemble
des pièces et en ce sens là je pense pas
qu'on a à blâmer le consommateur ou les
constructeurs mais il faut plutôt se
mettre en mode action pour être un
propulseur là de bonnes initiatives au
Québec et investir massivement dans les
technologies émergentes on peut penser
par exemple à l'hydrogène turquoise aux
piles à électrolytes solides il y a
toutes sortes de mesures de technologie
qui sont émergentes et à ce niveau là
Québec pourrait devenir un précurseur à
innover en matière d'énergie donc du
développement
la carotte peut être aussi pour des
encouragements et mes potes bâton pas de
bâton madame Alain
d'abord je pense que la solution elle
sera pas juste technologique ça passe
par un changement de comportement pour
ça ça prend des cœurs de villes et
villages avec des commerces de proximité
une économie plus locale des choses où
on peut se rendre à pied c'est une
question écologique mais c'est aussi une
question sociale pour des personnes
âgées ou des personnes qui ont pas les
moyens d'avoir des véhicules donc un
panier de solutions qui doit s'offrir
oui des meilleures technologies oui
inciter les gens à faire mieux que ce
soit par une carotte ou un bâton mais
effectivement je suis d'accord avec
Madame que il faut regarder un panier de
solution et pas juste une pièce vous
ajoutez qu'il faut changer nos habitudes
il y a des choses à changer dites-vous
moi je comprends madame Marel que vous
souhaitez pas qu'on change nos habitudes
je souhaite qu'on change l'écosystème
alors lorsqu'on parle de transport en
commun en ce moment au Québec dans les
régions si on sort de l'île de Montréal
si on sort de la région de Québec on a
des régions où le transport intra
régional ou inter régional et à peu près
pas exist à peu près pas développer donc
il faut vraiment changer l'écosystème
dans son ensemble plutôt que de blâmer
les individus ou les constructeurs il
faut que comme société on mette en place
les conditions gagnantes on parle de
plus en plus du TGV ça fait partie de
d'un portefeuille de solutions qui va
nous qui va complètement transformer
cette écosystème est-ce qu'on devrait
être salé interdire la publicité sur les
véhicules utilitaires sport je pense
qu'il y a une réflexion à faire la
publicité sert les producteurs sert pas
grand Autre bien social puis c'est pas
pour rien qu'on limite la publicité du
tabac ou de l'alcool
je trouve ça ironique qu'on fait dans
les publicités des viv c'est toujours
dans des milieux naturels vierges c'est
des véhicules on est en nature
en Amérique du Nord c'est là où on fait
le plus usage de ces véhicules et c'est
là où on a un étalement urbain puis un
empiètement sur nos milieux naturels
beaucoup plus fort alors il y a une
ironie à ça aussi
interdire la publicité sur les
vives on interdit la publicité sur le
tabac et on a taxé aussi les produits du
tabac et ça empêche pas les gens de
fumer les gens ont arrêté de fumer ceux
qui ont arrêté de fumer c'est pour des
raisons il y a quand même mieux un effet
de la publicité des taxes a quand même
ralenti le taux de tabagisme ben je
connais personne qui a arrêté de fumer à
cause des taxes c'est surtout pour les
soucis de santé donc en ce sens là ben
c'est important de s'assurer là qu'on
mette en mettre en place les conditions
et contiennent compte des réalités
régionales aussi parce que faut pas
oublier là les les véhicules utilitaires
sport puis même les pick-up là ils sont
ils sont utilisés ils sont vendus pas
par des gens qui habitent dans le
quartier Rosemont sont dans les régions
il faut pas nier aussi notre notre
étendu territoriale il faut vitaliser
nos régions et ça fait partie aussi de
notre réalité on est en territoire
nordique dans l'Est du Québec il y a
énormément de neige j'ai fait beaucoup
plus froid c'est complètement différent
je vous le dis aujourd'hui à Québec la
réalité pas la même qu'à Montréal du
tout et encore plus quand on s'en vient
dans l'est alors merci beaucoup c'était
très éloquent très intéressant
jacinthevaral et puis très salé merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir merci pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RD I